hey guys it's max in this video we are
comparing the brand new airpods max
to the sony xm4s i'm not going to say
the full name
and not only are we going to compare
their transparency and ambient modes
their active noise cancellation latency
over bluetooth
audio quality but we're also gonna look
at both an android phone with a higher
quality codec
and we're gonna stream some super high
quality 174 hertz
songs wired and see which one of these
deserves your money
let's get the cases out of the way and i
have to say that this case on the
airpods max
is probably apple's worst product of the
year
so far i haven't really used it i just
been leaving it by itself
it's inconvenient doesn't really protect
the airpods max that much apart from
bumping into each other
and the worst part is these don't turn
off there's no way to shut them off
um unless you put them in that case or
you can wait about two hours for them to
shut off
on their own now i'm gonna be doing some
battery life tests to see how much that
drains
and the overall battery life without
noise cancellation so click that button
below to subscribe if you want to see
that
and along with that you guys can help us
reach our goal of 550k
before the end of the year now for the
sony's this is the kind of a case that
most of us would prefer you get
protection all around
a nice hard case if you open them up not
only
well i opened up the wrong way but you
have access to your headphones you also
have little slots to store
cables to charge you get a little
adapter for airplanes
this is what i'm hoping third parties
will make for the airpods
now sony like most manufacturers gives
you a three and a half mil cable where
apple
you can also use the airpods max wired
but you have to spend another 35
bucks the airpods max have a single
lightning jack for
charging or for using it as wired
headphones so you can't use them both
wired and charged at the same time
whereas the sony's you actually have
both dedicated separate ports
so if you wanted to you could do that
but the charging cable
is very short of course you can use both
with bluetooth while you're charging and
as far as battery life the sony's are
rated for 30 hours
with active noise cancellation compared
to 20 hours
but it's interesting that the sound guys
they actually got about 18 to 19 hours
with the sony's
with their standard 75 decibel test
whereas with the earpods
they have actually surprised me with how
little battery they drain so i think
apple
may have understated them now the next
thing that really stands out is
weight the earpods max are actually
really heavy in my hand right now
the sony's are about 50 lighter but when
it comes to comfort
on your head i've actually been really
surprised
so i own a pair of xm3s
and even though they're fairly soft and
they're lightweight
you still feel the headband quite a bit
from the top and the actual
cushions here they're not as soft as you
would expect
so after about two to three hours they
do start becoming
a little bit of a pain and you get some
pressure built up the airpods max uses
very interesting net kind of design for
the headband
without anything over here so it's very
interesting when you put them on you
barely feel
the headband what i feel more is just
weight on the sides here
it's a little more substantial around
your ears but with
that this kind of a design for the ear
cups
is a quite a bit softer than the ones on
the sony so even though you feel the
weight
the pressure is lower so far the airpods
max have surprised me by how comfortable
they are on the head but i'm gonna have
to test them for a lot longer say
six hours eight hours at a time and i'll
let you guys know about long-term
comfort in the final review
along with the real world battery life
as far as build quality honestly
they do not compare i don't want to say
that the sony's
feel cheap they don't there's a lot of
other headphones that feel much cheaper
but they are completely made out of
plastic
which helps them be nice and lightweight
but they don't feel
premium they just feel decent or average
whereas the
all aluminum and stainless steel with
the nice texturized rubber
with the airpods max feel incredible
they're the best
most premium feeling headphones that
i've ever you know used in my life
now with that said one thing that i
don't like about the builder design at
least is that you can't fold these cups
in you can only twist them so they still
take up quite a bit of room what i
really love about the sony's
is that you can also fold these up like
this you can make them compact
makes it really easy to just toss them
into your bag
or your backpack and they just take up
much less room
along with that with the sonys i'm okay
with tossing them in my bag i'm not
worried about scratches
just because this has a plastic with a
little bit of rubberized coating
and the pad is more substantial i feel
like it's going to be
more durable without seeing any issues
or
any scratches whereas with the airpods
max not only am i worried about the
aluminum
scratching and you're going to see
silver underneath there
or maybe these bumping against each
other but also with this band that's
very minimal
i think it can scratch or rip much
easier and then of course along with
that we have a massive difference
in prices you're looking at right now
with the sale
about 280 bucks about half the price
compared to the airpods max so if you
damage and break them you just buy
another pair
now let's get into how you use these
headphones one thing that's great about
the max
is that you have perfectly fine minute
controls there's no little clicks so you
can get these exactly how you want them
to fit
and there's actually a lot of tension so
they're not gonna
accidentally move or adjust with most
headphones you have these little clicks
here
as you guys can hear and so there's a
little notches so you can't
dial in the adjustment exactly how you
want them
as far as controls the air pods have a
button to toggle between
your transparency mode and your active
noise cancellation
and you have this little digital crown
so what i love is that you can just
quickly pick up your hand
swipe one way or the other spin it
adjust your volume and you can press
down
a couple times if you want to skip
tracks or go back and the button feel is
excellent with the sony's this is
probably their biggest downfall you have
a touch sensitive
surface and with my xm3s they are
super sensitive it's hard to put in the
right controller sometimes you're just
using it on accident you're doing things
that you don't want to do and sony
they've realized that and they turned
down the sensitivity on the xm4s
but they turned them down too much so
now it's kind of hard
to put an input into there so overall i
really like the
controls on the airpods max now one
thing that's great about air pods is as
soon as you take them off it pauses your
music
which my xm3s didn't have but the xm4s
also have an optical sensor built into
here
so they actually do the same thing you
take them off your music pauses and that
is fantastic
as far as the ear cups or the pads the
airpods max are so easy to remove they
are magnetic so you guys see
they won't fall out but you can easily
remove them and you can buy different
colors
they are expensive though and with the
sony's they're not really designed to be
easily removable they're tucked in with
the material so if you pull it starts
kind of ripping this
material but there are replacements and
people have replaced them and the pros
say you should be
swapping them out about every two years
and now let's get into performance
we're gonna start out with active noise
cancellation
i'm gonna go ahead and put on the sony's
but before i turn on the ambient sound
control here
i just want to hear what it sounds like
just passively if you're trying to save
battery life
now that is a pretty good difference
right there a lot of that vent noise is
gone
my voice a lot of the high frequencies
are gone now
now let's go ahead and put on the
airpods max and even though they default
to active noise cancellation you can go
into the menu here and set it to off
all right that is interesting my voice
sounds more natural a lot of noise is
cut out
but that vent i still hear a little bit
of noise but the low end
whereas with the sony's i heard some
more of that higher
end frequencies now let's kick on
our active noise cancellation
okay my oh my voice sounds weird
i can still hear some of that vet noise
but some of the high frequencies
where it's like the air rushing through
vadim go ahead and say something
hey man how do you hear me you sound
very
weird do i yeah you sound like i usually
sound your voice sounds very
high frequency all the low end is just
gone
okay yeah but that is a that's a
very good um noise cancellation i'm
gonna put on these
toggle this on okay
wow i know they sounded good but putting
these head to head
all of that vent noise is gone my voice
is so much quieter
and it sounds natural it doesn't sound
nasally but you go ahead go ahead and
say something
hey how do you hear me you sound much
quieter
about the same as with the sony's but
your voice still sounds natural
you still have some bass you sound
normal but yes
so with the airpods max 100 of the ac
noise the central air that's always on
and loud in this room is completely
gone whereas with the sony's
i still hear a little bit of like the
high frequencies there
let's kick this up a notch i have some
white noise with
air compressor sounds here and i was
surprised
yesterday using these in my garage i'm
gonna set these down right here
i still hear i hear that modulation of
sound the pulsing
of the compressor oh yeah
massive difference all right yes there
definitely
is a difference i still hear everything
just like i did here
but these kick it down maybe a couple
more
decibels compared to the sony's so
when the sony's came out not long ago
they made a massive improvement over the
xm3s
mainly in that active noise cancellation
and sony said these are
the class leading the best on the market
apple also said these are class leading
but they definitely are the best that
i've heard
and they are a step above the sony's and
now let's go ahead and compare
the ambient mode and the transparency
mode with these headphones
just in case you want to hear what's
around you i'm going to start out with
the sony's and let's go ahead and kick
these up
and there is a little slider that opens
up here
and i'm going to set it to ambience wow
okay
interesting i have set to sound 20
let's go actually all right yeah so this
is kind of in between
so if you want to hear everything you
got to set it to sound 20. i'm gonna
turn off the focus whoa
okay wow so i turned that off the focus
on voice
let me hear the difference here it makes
everything sound higher frequency
a little bit digital but not too bad
definitely
a lot better than what i've heard from
other headphones and that vent noise it
sounds like it's still some noise
cancelling going on video go ahead and
say something
hit subscribe hit subscribe there you go
hit subscribe
uh say something else tap the like
button
yep how is it now is it changing at all
does it sound the same
or is it different it sounds more
nasally
you sound like you have your nose
plugged it's really it's
it's not it's fine yeah okay so i'm
gonna hit focus on voice here because
there's this option
well okay yeah go ahead how is it now
any different even more nasally really
it so it brings out your voice more so
compared to the background the
background has noise cancellation going
on so i can focus on your voice very
well but you don't sound natural
at all there's also this option called
speak to chat
so now we have noise cancellation and
then as soon as i start talking that's
about a three second delay
then it kicks you automatically into
ambient mode
alright so stop talking for a sec i
think it's supposed to go back into
noise cancellation mode but it's a
pretty cool feature if you wanted to
automatically switch
now let's go to the airpods max i have
them set to the off mode
and there's a lot of cancellation going
on by itself
transparency mode and wow okay
let's switch between that sounds like 99
of real life that is crazy off you hear
so little go to transparency mode it's
piping all that in here and it's all
fake but it sounds so natural my voice
sounds true to life but you need to go
ahead and say something hey man how is
it on the airpods max
okay say it again how is it on the
airpods max you sound
almost identical to your voice a little
bit higher
but almost identical so i'm hearing the
vent
just like it literally sounds like the
event sounds identical
all right so the transparency mode on
the airpods max is
worlds worlds above the sony's i don't
know if they improved it or not compared
to last year but the difference is
insane
and even if you're not gonna buy these
go to the apple store and test them out
that is just shocking
and now let's go ahead and do a
microphone comparison we're gonna start
out in this room
where we had a lot of the hvac noise so
it's gonna have to deal with that
and then we're gonna move into a quieter
room this is the microphone quality of
the sony xm4s
in a fairly noisy room and this is the
microphone quality of the airpods max in
a fairly
noisy environment and now let's go into
that much quieter room and see how
they compare in that environment this is
the microphone quality
of the sony xm4s in a really quiet room
this is the microphone quality of the
airpods max
in a really quiet room alright guys let
me know your thoughts was there a big
difference in this
noisy room and what about the difference
in the quiet room go ahead and comment
down below
and now let's go ahead and do a latency
test for those of you guys that want to
do some gaming
or maybe some video editing or some
other things while using these
headphones in bluetooth mode i'm going
to start out
with the airpods max i have call of duty
mobile
open up right here let's go ahead and
hit the menu bar
alright so that was actually very little
latency
i do hear a slight delay if i'm trying
to focus on it i know with the airpods
pro we tested those at about 150
milliseconds
these are no worse than that possibly
even better
and vadim yesterday actually played call
of duty mobile for a couple of hours and
he said they worked
perfectly he couldn't tell he got into
the game he didn't notice any delay
now let's put on the sony's oh yeah
much more of a difference so this is
probably like a third of a second
difference or so so if you're going to
be gaming i mean it's not as bad as some
of the samsung's i've tested which those
are over half a second about 700
milliseconds
this is probably about 300 or so it's
about twice as much of a delay
compared to the airpods max i also
wanted to try these with
android so i have the pixel 5 here and
it's making me go through the tutorial
i think the delay is actually worse here
let me try that again
yeah no longer is it about 300
milliseconds this is at least
half a second yeah when i press it it's
at least half a second now now with the
xm3s you did have a aptx codec
that had less delay but with xm4s you
don't have the option i'm using
ldac right now and because of that the
delay is pretty bad and it's interesting
that it's actually worse on android than
ios
and now let's get into sound quality
we're gonna listen to a few different
genres
even to some ultra high quality audio
wired
i'm gonna start out with the sony's with
our typical song
i'm gonna go ahead and take a listen and
then i'll give you guys my opinions
[Music]
all right guys that was interesting
first off
they are much closer together than i
expected
a lot of the sounds are fairly similar
and this is an edm track in our previous
tests we found this is the least
difficult one to reproduce
i know there's a couple differences
though as far as the overall
bass the sony's actually output more
bass and one thing that really stood out
is
you have more of that deep lower bass
and it sounds a little bit more boomy
and the air pods they still have a lot
of low in bass but you have more
separation between that really low
rumble kind of base and then the popping
base that comes out
where with the sony's they kind of blend
in a little bit together and then the
other difference i noticed is the vocals
they're a little bit more bright on the
sony's uh where they sound a little bit
maybe more natural a little bit more
subdued
with the airpods so let's go ahead and
switch to another genre
this is a modern classical track with
some piano and some low notes
[Music]
all right all right all right wow that
was definitely
a lot more different than the first song
i love the song guys
now it's getting stuck in both but even
my had
what can i say um i liked the extra bass
out of these
maybe i'm a bass head i don't know the
bass definitely stands out more there's
more of it and it sounded great in the
song
which is like that deep bass that
sounded great
the other thing i noticed is these
definitely have a better sound stage
with the sonys they're definitely better
than earbuds it feels like the sound is
right around here
right i get a little bit of separation i
get some instruments moving around but
with the air pods it feels like
the speakers around me are twice as far
away
the sound stage is much wider and
the i don't know if i would say
localization of instruments certain
parts it feels like i moved my hands
like right here instead of
somewhere here it's further away and
that sweep
just sounded so much more dramatic and
the same thing with the piano
i almost feel like there's keys instead
of just switching from one ear to the
other
bam bam bam right in front of me as he's
playing down
and then towards the end there with that
sweep
we got some distortion with the sony's
just like with the airpods pro
in yesterday's video whereas the earpods
max had
absolutely no distortion and they
definitely sounded better and now
let's make it even more difficult we
have a rock track here in our previous
testing
this is much more difficult for
headphones to play so let's go ahead and
take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
is
okay i don't want to say this is a
bigger difference
than our previous track but it sounds
uh the difference between those two
tracks were crazy
um these sound more like the airpod pros
i know it's kind of weird to say
they sound almost flat in this song
where they absolutely didn't they were
more colored in the previous one
the separation between the different
bass and the bass guitar and the drums
there
there wasn't much at all just like
earbuds whereas here there is
much more separation and the actual
bass guitar and then the drums there's a
lot more richness
and depth and one thing that i was
looking for in these
that i didn't hear when you have all
that sound towards the beginning
there's almost like a violin in the
background where
with these you can actually hear it and
i never heard it before that the airpod
pros
i didn't hear it with the sony's but
they do send stand out here so the
separation between the instruments is
much greater with the airpod pros
i want to make sure that i'm getting the
best sound out of these so i connected
it to the pixel 5 using that ldac
codec and this is a high quality stream
still from youtube but it's 1080p
let me take a listen i'll get back to
you guys
[Music]
yeah it sounds identical i honestly
can't tell a difference maybe if it was
a better source
but that little violin in the background
with all the bass and electric guitar
and drums all smashed together i still
don't hear it
on the sony's where i do on the airpod
max which
these only use aac connection and now
it's time for the
ultimate test i connected the wire here
and i have this crazy high quality file
thank you hi-fi insider a view of our
channel for sharing this this is
recorded by
m a audio the file's over 500 megabytes
it's 176
kilohertz uncompressed audio so let's go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
okay wow overall
wow i guess i have to start listening to
more audio that's really high quality
uncompressed through wired so listening
to that track
with these plugged in really opened up
these headphones it was the first time
instead of
the sound stage just being you know
slightly wider
it expanded further out more so closer
to the airpod max about the same level
and i started hearing the piano going
around and some interesting
instruments moving around definitely
made these sound better but a couple
times i actually had to turn down
the volume because it started distorting
i turned it down a little bit and the
layer turned down more
even more so it's pretty loud very
interesting that with the earpods
overall even at the start they started
out quieter
i kept them full blast all the time i
know you probably shouldn't do that but
i love it like that
uh they were a little bit quieter and
there was no distortion whatsoever
now with that the sound stage was even
wider
with this song and there's more
separation between the different
instruments
and just made me want to learn to play
piano that sounded really good
and i also noticed some more room noise
so this was recording with really really
high end stereo mics
in like a cathedral i heard more of the
room noise and some background noises
that was going on while they were
recording this so
definitely these sound better and no
distortion at all but these also sounded
pretty good
after i turned them down alright guys
it's finally time for the conclusion
are the airpods max worth twice as much
as
the sony's and to be honest this is a
very difficult question but i've been
thinking about it i'm going to try to
break it down for you guys
if you're somebody that is mainly
looking for a pair of headphones that
are really good for active noise
cancellation
and audio comes second or
if you're on a budget and you know you
can't afford these we can afford these
or lastly if you listen to mostly edm
some more similar type of music these
are a great option sure the active noise
cancellation
isn't as good but it's close ambient
mode is much worse
but the sound for that kind of more
simple music it does a good job a lot of
bass
it's more color the high notes stand out
more it sounds great in that aspect
but if you care about convenience
especially with iphones
and you want the music to sound above
just an
average pair of headphones definitely
the airpods max
they're on a whole nother level as far
as sound stage separation
especially for rock music and even
classical
it sounds much better definitely take a
listen to a pair yourselves at an apple
store
these are starting to get into the audio
file range with a lot of conveniences
and active noise cancellation
where these are just all around decent
quality sound
with really good active noise
cancellation my audio technica's
actually sound better than these and
those are about 150 bucks they are wired
though
and in reality if you care about active
noise cancellation
you might just want to get a pair of air
pod pros the sound quality other than
the extra bass
is very similar between these two you
just get a little bit worse active noise
cancellation but a lot more convenience
and in fact
i actually just use my airpod pros
instead of the sony xm3s
because there's not that big of a
difference so that's it for me guys
um the sony's are great great price way
better case
but these if you can afford them they
are on another level go ahead and click
that circle above if you want to
subscribe and see our full in-depth
review with
long-term comfort battery life and more
and check out one of those other two
great videos right over there we have
links down in the video description
some great prices this has been max and
i'll see you in the next video